well from open borders to catch and
release look at these polls they show
that 63 percent of iowa voters
disapprove of the way joe biden is
handling immigration
it's his worst issue by far and that
might be one of the reasons why iowans
elected republicans to represent their
state because republicans like governor
kim reynolds and senator joni ernst they
promised to strengthen the border and
protect american jobs yet this week they
did the opposite when they learned that
some eighteen thousand afghans had
applied for visas to the united states
they jumped at the opportunity to waive
them in
i think the message that i want to relay
to iowans is that we want to be a
partner we want them here and we want
them to know that and we'll work through
those processes whatever they may be
they're wonderful they've supported our
men and women in uniform they love
america they are hard workers we would
love to welcome them into the state
so joining me now the author of the new
book the long slide which is available
both in stores but more importantly
directly at tuckercarlson.com and of
course the host of the show right after
this one tucker carlson tucker glad to
have you on the show um you've been all
over this story all week i've been
watching you talking about refugees
being moved to the united states from
afghanistan here we are listening to
republicans who seem to have a charge
from their voters to be strong on
immigration
doing exactly the opposite of what their
voters want
so i'm watching that i mean first i
think we should note that americans are
welcoming to refugees and immigrants
because they're decent open-minded
big-hearted people and that says
something good about the united states
but the sort of blitheness the lack of
concern about details from our leaders
really tells you how little they care
about us i watched joni ernst say that
we welcome them really to your house to
your neighborhood i don't think so to
some sad little town with no power
whatsoever no one will ever go five
years from now to see how it's going no
one's interested in
the story of how it unfolds on the
effects of on your life on your schools
on your infrastructure on your taxes
does it make you happy or does it
improve your life you think joni ernst
cares are you kidding no they go before
the cameras message i care i'm a good
person i'm compassionate you
you know
who cares what you think you're just a
citizen
um so it really rev this is not an
attack on the refugees for whom i think
all people really feel i certainly do
i'd want to get the hell out of
afghanistan i get it but what about
americans how does it affect their lives
have you ever been to a place where
there's been mass refugee resettlement i
have i live near one actually it's very
tough to resettle large groups of people
very tough tough to assimilate them it's
very tough for the people who already
live there but nobody cares joni ernst
clearly doesn't care why would you vote
for joni ernst after that i wonder i
don't know maybe they will again i saw
you talking about that earlier this week
being very honest about the successful
nature of or the lack of the successful
nature of of re-um re-situating refugees
not just in the united states but across
europe as well it's been a real
hit-and-miss operation across the globe
but here's the thing you talked about
this tucker you said look americans have
a big heart we want to help out and how
do we walk this how do we walk this line
there is this sense that we do owe these
people who helped us out in a time of
war we do owe them something so how do
we balance what we might owe them to
what we owe ourselves in terms of our
country our safety and all the values
that voters care about
well i mean first identify the the
people to whom we really do owe
something and then make the case i mean
not all posh tunes are the same not all
tajiks are the same just because you're
from afghanistan doesn't mean you help
the united states or you're a hero maybe
maybe joni ernst could head over to
kabul and personally screen these people
maybe peter meyer of michigan could do
the same this sort of shut up their
heroes what are you a racist
by the way they're like white guys and
beards race has nothing to do with this
let's take that off the table it's about
a country that's deeply divided hours
that's getting poorer hours and the
effect on our country of mass
immigration whether it's refugees or
people from guatemala or haiti or any
part of the world that might want to
come here how does it affect us that's
not only a fair question it's the main
question and it's never asked by anyone
in charge that tells you everything
about how they feel i think here's a
great example of that by the way exactly
what order of priority do americans
maintain in most of these politicians
minds right now there are americans
behind enemy lines in essence in
afghanistan and wendy sherman she set up
stood up to the podium today this is the
first thing she said before she talked
about this was yesterday before she
talked about americans or anybody else
this is the first thing she had to say
watch
before i take your questions
i want to speak to a situation that's
very personal to me societies
could not flourish
and prosper
without the full participation of women
and girls back then
and they cannot and flourish they cannot
flourish and prosper without women and
girls now
now that's i'm sure something we can
both agree on that women and
the prospering of women that everybody
is for that but before we get americans
out from behind enemy lines that needed
to be addressed
what i love about that it's such a
perfect distillation wendy sherman's a
buffoon obviously she's implicated in
this disaster people like wendy sherman
got us there kept us there for 20 years
she should apologize but she doesn't the
first thing she does is she said i want
to take a second to talk about myself
and then to give you a self-righteous
moral lecture about how i'm better than
you i mean that's like the perfect
distillation of everything everything
the preface is always but enough about
you let me talk about me for a second
and my concerns in my history my lived
experience
and what a good person i am so with that
aside now to your questions oh shut up
racist another one shut up racist i mean
how long were people gonna put up with
this how about enough about you wendy
sherman how about us like 340 million
people who live in a country that's
getting worse how are you gonna improve
our lives any answer no i doubt it uh
this next uh question for you uh i think
it's actually a good opportunity to talk
about your book by the way you have a
book out we just mentioned the long
slide 20 years in journalism and i think
the last time i talked to you on air i
started to go down this path and i asked
you when it is you think the media lost
their way was it always so slanted but
here i want to ask you instead about the
american people i've been shocked and
i've been talking about it this week
tucker you know
media
politicians elites corporations they're
corrupt they're perhaps irredeemably
corrupt and we can see that now and it's
manifesting in these coveted policies
it's not science it's scientism but i'm
a little taken aback tucker by my fellow
americans americans who not just are
compliant but so many that become the
enforcers of this anti-science sort of
authoritarian nature over each other and
i just wonder like what is it about our
fellow americans that have embraced this
idea of let me force my other ideas on
you
yeah i mean unfortunately the entire
country is being manipulated by highly
clever ruthless people who are
harnessing the worst qualities in human
nature
you know lynchings have happened
throughout history not just simply in
this country but in all countries
because there's something in people that
wants to turn on the unpopular kid and
beat him to death that's like who we are
that's the ugliest part of who we are
and if you have ruthless leaders who are
willing to exploit that for their own
gain and we do
then they wind up turning the population
against itself and vaccinated
unvaccinated white black these divisions
which we didn't recognize a year ago are
now defining our lives
and we're being used i mean that's the
truth if you want to subdue people
divide them and that's exactly what
they're doing and i you know people
shouldn't participate in it but again
they're harnessing human nature against
us i think that's exactly right and then
the next obvious question is used by
whom for what purpose
yeah well for control of course i mean
smoke more weed you know here's netflix
just sewn out we got this really oh you
got it huh is that going to help me
probably not
so not only do you have the long slide
out your new book but there is another
passion that we actually have in common
and that is the idea of ufos i'm pretty
fascinated by this and you have a new
fox nation special about ufos what's
that about
well i mean there's just a huge amount
of evidence that the u.s government for
70 years has been tracking these objects
that are real they're not a foreign
government they're not human beings
inside we know because the g-forces they
exhibit are beyond what people could
could withstand
and they've lied about it for all these
years the question is why what are these
things kind of a big story if you think
about it it's not a figment of our
imagination they're absolutely real they
defy science as we understand it so like
what the hell why is that not the
biggest story i mean i know covet is the
biggest story like the flu but ufos are
real i mean that how's that for a
headline i was in the news business for
a long time i guess i still am that's a
headline europa's a real what and we
sort of like blow past oh yeah okay fine
no no
in a year of covet and and and race and
everything else you're right the
government acknowledged that ufos exist
and that just kind of flew under the
radar
all right really quickly yeah
it's like a million miles an hour right
really quickly what can we expect from
the long slide as well
uh well the book is out it's just you
know 30 years of journalism it really
it's i think someone's pretty good i
liked listening to people back when i
was a print guy you have to listen
you're not always on transmit like i am
now
and i think it held up pretty well but
you get a sense of how much the country
has changed yeah i like you talked about
a lot of the people you've known along
the way and how they've changed as well
people that used to be friends
i've experienced that same kind of thing
when you live in one side of the media
yeah yeah i have i bet i'm open to still
being friends i'm open to it me too
all right that's right politics is not
the most important thing to me that's
for sure that's exactly right well kane
thank you 20 minutes we'll see you on
tucker carlson tonight thanks tucker
thank you see you man see you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else